there's this belief that the united
states is the best place in the entire
world to have a baby and that's not true
it's the most dangerous place in the
developed world
my name is michelle hartney i live in
chicago and i'm an artist
a lot of people don't know that our
maternal mortality rate in the united
states has increased 160
since 1995.
many of our routine practices like
continuous monitoring and forcing
mothers to give birth on their backs are
not based on scientific evidence
there are still a lot of doctors that
are not doing what what's best for women
i'm approaching these issues with my art
art can hit you deeper than just reading
a statistic on a page can
i started a series called mother's write
i spent the summer sewing 1200 hospital
gowns one for every woman who died
during childbirth in 2013.
the fabric of the gowns is made up of
the plant derivatives of the drugs that
have been used on laboring women for the
past 150 years
we had a performance at daily plaza in
chicago the performance included pairs
of women folding the gowns into the
shape of a flag similar to the way the
flag is folded at the funeral of a
soldier to also
bring awareness to the number of women
who are coming out of childbirth with
the same psychological symptoms as men
and women who are fighting wars what
inspired me really it was
the birth experience of my my second
child
i mean ultimately both of my birth
experiences were empowering but there
were things that happened
during the birth of my son that just
didn't feel right
lying your back those are my words that
my doctor told me when i was trying to
give birth on my side and they were
trying to get me to lie in my back
doctors should know that you can push
baby out on your side
i was with experts
so that's where birth words came from
a lot of the phrases are really
disturbing but they're actually things
that doctors were saying
to their patients while they were giving
birth
and i've had people think that i made
them up because it's hard to believe
that a doctor would say suck it up and
get over it or if you don't shut up we
will knock you out
my artwork is not trying to say that
that doctors are bad or hospitals are
bad
what i'm trying to say is that women
need to know that they need to be
informed when they're going into
childbirth
i want my daughter if she has a baby to
be giving birth in different
circumstances than we are now
women have a choice and that knowledge
can change the way that we are
experiencing childbirth in the united
states
you